Hey guys, Will, really, your hair is really growing in there. It's very long. Sean, I'm going to go ahead and let you start again. We need a little bit more enthusiasm when we're starting this episode. Sorry, sorry. Hey, Will's hair. And welcome to an Old New Smurfs. You know, listener, every once in a while, Will and Sean and I have to have an adult conversation. We have to do a little bit of a Zoom,
we need to talk about scary legal things. And we just had one of those before this record, and Sean got a real head full of steam going in his legal prowess, and talking about how he looked through these documents and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And in walks an order of, presumably from an off camera Scotty, two frosted strawberry pop tarts
and a half a glass of milk. That's right. And he keeps talking and all his legal, he starts choking on his fucking frosted pop tart offering legal advice to me and Will. At one point he says to you, Jason, he goes with a mouthful of Pop-Tart, he goes, if you want to sign it to me,
I'd love, I'd love to sign it. And I go, you didn't even know the fucking document you were signing, Pop-Tart? Yes, I did. Yes, I did. Jason just got back from vacation, how lovely. I'm very lovely and relaxed. Will looks like he's been on vacation for six months.
He's got some new lighting in the Whisper booth there. I don't, he's got a new light. And he's got a nice tan from his Long Island condo. The light is great out here in the condo and I was able to, you know, via the kindness of others, get out and play some golf. So I've been and spent a lot of time with the kids out here.
We've been out at the beach a lot. Quick, what are their names? Terrence, Glad Phil. Nope, that's wrong. Karen. You don't even have a girl. It's four boys. Okay. Karen. Well, you caught have a girl. It's four boys. Okay.
Karen. Well, you caught me off guard. How's everybody doing? I always feel like Jason and I, we never get to see you anymore. I know, it's so wrong. Sean and I were FaceTiming last night. We were like, we haven't seen,
we never get to talk to Jason anymore. It's been working. And even sometimes we do talk to him, and then Sean was like, yeah, no, but we never get to meet the real Jason anymore. You know what I mean? Well, he only goes out on Saturday nights. I was talking about you guys on my break
about the fact that you guys do talk all the time and we never talk. Well, you're working 15 hours a day. No, but even when I'm not. You hate a Zoom and you hate a Zoom. No, it's not about the Zoom. It's just, no, I'm just not, why am I not that kind of a friend
that like talks every day to his best friends? I'll tell you why. Because you're always working, and when you have downtime, you just wanna be by yourself, which I get. You guys are so good about, do you have like, I mean, I know, Will, you've got like a nightly chat with the great Josh Otlin.
Yeah. And probably with Sean P. Hayes. I talk to a lot of people pretty much on the reg. I talk to Sean, not every night. Short for regular listener. Short for regular. Once a week, probably. Twice a week, maybe.
I talk to Clay every other day. I talk to Eli. And Jason, I always text you first before we talk. But you know what's one of those things, you gotta also do it and it's like, I know. You and Sweet Pete Giles would be great best friends because you guys like spending a lot of time alone.
And you know. We've got a bunch of dolls with pins. You sent me a nice picture from your trip with that bucket, that sweet ass Sergio Zucchini bucket hat that I bought you last year. Yeah, and I showed you, it was at good use, you know. And don't you have a collection of puppets that you play with, Jason?
Yeah, they talk to me all the time. And you're also still really good friends with your gummies. Yeah, oh my God, I talk to them, they never speak to me, but I'm speaking to them all the time. Can we please just give, I think the kids usually say a shout out to, a holla or whatever to our new host.
And they might holla back, Youngin. Yeah. Of our podcast, Bad Dates, the new host Joel Kim Booster. He's hilarious. He is gonna be guiding us through all the legendary and insane true bad date stories, the amazing guest reveal, with all of their gory details you loved in season one.
Yeah, it sounds so natural when you say it like that. But no, this is our smart list media show called Bad Dates. We love this show. It was with Jamila Jamil, and now it's with Joel Kim Booster, and it's gonna be just as great. And everybody has bad dates, everybody can relate to them. Yeah, we can relate to them.
And so I... And JKB is gonna, by the way, my same initials, fun fact. He's gonna walk you through it. Yeah, so you can find new episodes anywhere you get your podcast. Because we all know the worst dates make the best stories. Ooh, that should be a line,
that should be a tagline on the show. Let's get some bumper stickers going. I'm really excited. I'm almost as excited about that as I am about my guest. My guest today. And you guys are gonna be excited too. Now first of all, man, this is nuts. Because this is one of those people that I have, and I don't want to embarrass him, and
he kind of knows that I don't know, but I super look up to him, which is not the most articulate thing I've ever said, but it is just it. I have been such a fan of what this guy does for so long, and there's an authenticity to who he is and how he does it that I've always just really responded to and frankly so have audiences around him. Millions. Well, I mean, look, he's been nominated for like 120 awards. He's won 70 of them and everything.
70? Yeah. What kind of awards? Like from Critics' Choice to Gotham Awards to Independent Spirit Awards, to MTV Movie Awards, to Satellite Awards, Saturn Awards, Teen Choice Awards, Film Critics Awards, Green Actors Awards, Prime Time Emmy Awards, Golden Globe Awards, and BAFTA Awards, and Academy Awards.
Christian Bale. The old school Academy Awards. He doesn't have 70 wins. I mean, he's good, that guy, Christian Bale, but he doesn't have 70. He doesn't have 70. This guy. This guy, you doesn't have 70 wins. I mean, he's good, that guy, but Christian Bale, but if he doesn't have 70, this guy. This guy, you don't remember him from his first television appearance, which was on Mr. Roger's Neighborhood,
way back in the way, in the day. You might remember him as co-starring with David Letterman on the Mary Tyler Moore hour. You're more likely to remember him from things like Mr. Mom, Gung Ho, Michael Keaton. But to me, he is my Batman. You guys, it's Michael Keaton.
Welcome to the show, Michael. You've got sunglasses on. Why do you have sunglasses on? Sorry. You forgot. Good morning. Because I'm pretentious. Forget about that whole authentic thing.
I had sunglasses on. I don't know. You're gonna wipe it out. Yeah. Well, this is interesting. Hello. Thanks. Hi, how are you?
Welcome. You know, the preamble. It's obnoxious, I know. No. It's too much. First of all, I was gonna be a smart ass, but after Will being so sweet, now I can't be. No, you can't.
Please, please be a smart ass. Oh, I can? Okay, yeah. Please, please do. I would think that if there's one area, one format, one show, one could be a smart ass, this would be. Yeah, it's half vital. Welcome, yeah. Where are we finding you?
Where's that pretty, pretty wall that looks like a cabin of some sort? This is, well, this is my home in Montana. Well, this is the cabin of the property because the other house is being rebuilt. And- Did it burn down? Not down, but see, see what, see smart ass?
I can't help it. You're gonna have to bear with me. Yeah, you threw something out there, and now it's hurtful. So yeah, and this little house was reassembled from up the valley or down the valley, up the valley many years ago, but that's where I am.
That's where I'm sitting. That's so nice. But you know, listen to the whole thing, the how you guys do this. I have so many questions. Sure, go ahead. Go ahead, hit us. Do you validate personal?
We do. It's stickers. It's one of your questions, why would anybody listen to you idiots? No, no, no. We can't figure it out, you know. Well, let me ask this. Yeah.
You all have either adapted or you always had it. You all now have like a radio voice. Did you always have this radio voice? We're learning from Will. Will makes millions with those pipes. Yeah, I did. Give him professional grade. Seriously, Jason, you've got kind of a calm,
groovy thing going, you know, like you're laid back. It's gummy induced. Yeah, well, however you get there, you know, like you're laid back. It's gummy induced. Yeah, well, however you get there, you got that thing, shaw-ish. Mine's just annoying in Chicago. No, yours is very witty. Okay, well there you go. I'm cutting you in a minute.
Here comes Will. And Will just kinda, you know, I didn't know, I swear to God this is true, when I would see those Reese's commercials, I'd say, that dude's funny. I swear to God I didn't know who it was. There's a few people out there I'm looking at right now, and I saw, I watched these commercials,
I saw a guy the other day. He's so, I don't know who that guy is. He's so funny and so good in it, and I was reminded of how hard it is to crack open, to have people see you, to find a spot, you know? And we've been fortunate. With just your voice, you can. Yeah, no, seriously. Okay, Sean, I find a spot, you know? And we... With just your voice each other. Yeah, no, seriously.
Okay, Sean, I have a question for you. Did you and I not, many, many years ago, you were already nodding, right? We met a long time ago because you were working for a... No, not for a long time. Yeah, I was saying many times. Don't embarrass him now. He's about to give you, he's just olive wrenching it
and then you cut him off with the fucking many times? What's wrong with you, Sean? He'll smile you right through the night. Jesus fuck. He'll smile you right through the night. Go ahead, sorry. That's right, that's his super power. You used to work for, am I wrong?
You used to work for a catering company or something. Is this true when you were getting started? The very first year I worked at a restaurant called Red and then part of that was to, you know, sometimes people would, oh, I'm doing a wedding so I do like, to make an extra 100 bucks, I would help out like. Yes.
Yeah, and it was, yeah. And I met you at a party, didn't I? That's right, yes. And I said, who's this funny guy? This guy's so witty. That was, that was. Let's hear this. That was like over 30 years ago.
What an impression. And also, but I kept meeting you over and over, and Michael, we can cut this if you'd like, so don't worry. And I kept meeting you over and over because you used to date Julie Bowen. For a minute, yeah, yeah, she's great. Yeah, and I used to be friends with Julie Bowen, and I would always running to add parties
Yeah, yeah, yeah, and and at that yeah that white cut it By the way, by the way, why cut it? But also, you know what you could say so that you don't have to kind of say and also we both know Julie Bowen You could have said that Sugar yeah, I am kind of flying Yeah, you know pop tart sugar. Yeah, I am kind of flying Jason's on a gummy. I'm on fire. I got fired from that job right Sean you ate into their profits Is that the way no Mike Michael with it wasn't that I think it was at? Who played goose in the in the original?
What's his name Anthony? Oh, yeah, it was it was at Anthony Edwards house, and he was having a wedding for somebody I don't know, but don't go deeper, because you already know a poor Julie in a bad spot. Michael, do you remember? Now Julie's in a bind. She's having to explain to somebody where she was. It was so easy just to say, yes, we did, that's what happened.
Yes, 70 years ago, somebody was saying, fucking Julie was, remember she wasn't around, it turns out she was hanging, Jesus. No, but I will say, every single time I ran into you, whether it was when I was around Julie or not, one of the nicest guys, always, always, always. Oh, well, thanks. Yeah, always, and super funny,
and allowed me to be funny in front of you. You were very generous. I like funny people. Michael, I don't know if you know this, too, our mutual friend is Courtney Cox from years ago, and a good friend of ours, and Jason was just on vacation with her, we were talking about, and I remember friend is Courtney Cox from years ago and a good friend of ours and Jason was just on vacation with her, we were talking about. And I remember saying to Courtney,
I used to be, this is like 10 years ago, I go, what's my uncle like? I used to flip out because I was such a fan of yours for so long. Oh yeah, still is, probably still is. And so what I wanna get into, and that's gonna get me to my first thing, which is two things.
Two movies that to me were like, and they're not underrated because they were big hits, but first of all, Mr. Mom to me was a genre changer, right? Nobody done a movie like that. You did it with such ease. And the great part was it wasn't putting down a stay at home parent. In fact, it was pumping it up. 100%. And it was so, to me, that was what was so interesting
about it, you know what I mean? Especially those were different days back then. But you did it in this way that kind of took that on and flipped it on its head. What was it like getting that, reading that script, getting that offer, deciding whether to do it, shooting it, all of it? I've, reading that script, getting that offer, deciding whether to do it, shooting it, all of it?
I've always loved that movie, man. So I'm really glad you brought this up. First of all, and then let's get this out of the way because I kind of hate this part. I'm a giant fan of all three of you guys. But here's why that's a really good question and I'm glad you asked it. Because you know, I'll sometimes when I'm doing,
I don't do a lot of them, but I'm doing an interview or being interviewed or something, I will actually volunteer Mr. Mom for a bunch of reasons. A, it was ahead of its time. And how it came to be, and it was John Hughes' first, yeah, I think it was the first script he sold. Wow. And then he became John Hughes. Yeah, John Hughes wrote it.
And I was sitting and he was pitching me, even didn't have to pitch it. You guys all will know this. When you're reading a script, a comedy script, and the Goodwins don't come around very often, and you laugh out loud by yourself, let's say, two, three, four times a script, you go, whoa, that's huge.
Am I right? That's huge. And you go, okay. That's the number too. It's only about two or three or four times, but it's like, that's amazing. It is amazing. And the average layman, let's say, wouldn't know that,
but that's how it works. So I remember saying, I remember actually one thing he did, and it was an area that I generally don't laugh or find funny, was the baby had diarrhea. And my head went back, I was in, my head went back so far, it hit the wall in the back. My head hit the wall, I thought, because it was how it was presented, how it was set up,
and where it came in the script, where he got me, where you were at that point. And I went, boom, right there, that thing kills me right now. So I sat with him, I said, listen to him, he was not without an ego and I liked him, but I said, you should direct this thing, you know how to make this movie. He said, no, I'm not gonna direct.
He was a Chicago ad guy. And so what I knew about it was, A, it was funny. And I also liked kind of the time. The reason I thought I couldn't do it was I looked like I was about 10 years old. And I thought, and then we had to kind of write that in because I thought, okay, let's say you married young. And how do we really believe this? Because as you all three will know, if you don't, it can be as outrageous, as funny as like Jim Carrey or the craziest guys are,
they set up their own reality, right? So once you, it's like Carson used to say, you buy the premise, you buy the joke. So if you set, you go, yeah, that's crazy what he's doing, but it's actually not crazy. In his world. In that, that's right, in that world. So I said, how do we believe this guy?
Because that's the only way this thing is gonna work. And there was a lot of rewriting on the set, I will say, between me and my then manager partner, Harry Columbia, and some other people. It was a great cast. And so what I dug about it was, A, it was funny. I liked playing a father because I liked being a father. I liked what it was about. And it was ahead of its time in that at the time, the US economy was not very good. And it was hard, you know, the unemployment was not great. And the idea of a woman going out to the workforce is crazy as it sounds.
And whenever we shot that 80 something. Eighty three. Eighty three was not that unusual, but it was fucking unusual to, by comparison. Right. And I like the, you know, I have three sisters and a mom. Most people who work for me are women. I didn't plan it that way, it's just how it is. So I like that whole setup and the premise, and I thought, okay, now how do we make,
now let's just make this funny. So it was already funny, but there were things, because the director, who was a talented guy, but he was not a comedy guy, we had to work on, let's say. And there was a lot of rewriting going on and as an example, the whole chainsaw thing came about on the morning because as we were getting ready to do it, there was no chainsaw scene.
There was no, That didn't exist. The great, late, great Martin Moe... Yeah, I was gonna say that. ...comes in and says, you know, he's taking Terry off. I have so much to say about this, because not enough credit is given to Terry Gahr. Well, I was gonna get... Oh, my God. I'm gonna get into Terry Gahr in a second, so keep going.
Okay, I'll finish. I'm sorry, going on too long. No, no, I love it. But so, that scene was one thing, right? But what I knew was, I said, but how does this guy feel? How insecure is he right now? And how emasculated is he right now? And Martin walks in just fucking cocksure, you know? Just beautifully played, like looking, just fucking beautifully played,
like looking so brilliantly arrogant, looking at me and I'm thinking, okay, what would this guy do when I, he's panicked, he's not ready for this. So I said to the prop guy, he'd get me like, I don't know, I'd like he's pretending he's working on the house, you know, like tools or something,
and he shows me a chains cycle. I go, yes. And I said, run down, you have any of those goggles? And I go, yeah, he goes and gets the goggles. And then we just played it from there. Obviously insecure, obviously scared to death. Overcompensating. Overcompensating out of his ass. And then the 220 line was Martin's.
It was Martin's line. What was the line again? I said, yeah, I'm probably going to rewire the whole thing. And that was the end of that. And Martin said, you know what you should say? Martin says something like, how are you going to wire it? And I go, I don't know. He says, you should say 220, 221, whatever it takes.
That's Martin Moll's line. I keep telling people that. That was not me. And by the way, the movie you did before that Night Shift, I watched over and over and over. Oh my God. I loved that movie. And the one line that stuck out in my head, of course,
is when you're like, we could just feed the tuna, the mayonnaise, so you don't have to get it open. And as a kid I was like, that's such a genius idea. Just feed the tuna fish. The mayonnaise. That's such a genius idea. You know, Willie, now that I was just listening to Michael talk, it strikes me that I'll bet you
Michael Keaton is an enormous influence on your style. I mean, you actually remind me of one another. That's a compliment to me, not to him. That's a compliment, you're a compliment to me. Yeah, for sure. By, you know what I mean? Unintentionally, sorry.
I know, I know, because yeah, and I meant it when I said it is huge influence, and I wanna get into, because then there were so many other films too that I thought I deserved a lot of attendance one of them being clean and sober which I think is a Phenomenal film not just because I could relate To what what he went through, but I just think it's a great with the great MM at Walsh I mean, there's just some amazing moments in that film but I do want to talk about Terry Gar for one second because I also loved Terry Gar.
And what was that like? I mean, what an unbelievable talent, am I right? The spirit. Oh man. And who, you know, you look at all the really great, funny women, there's so many now, and there were kind of relatively speaking, so few then. But they're really great.
Well they didn't write the great parts of them back then, right? No, no. And you know, look at Terry, man. She had everything. She still has everything. She's so sweet. I just love her.
I think Catherine Hahn is like a modern day Tony Gardner. Totally. Yeah. And you look at, you know, she's witty and funny and feminine and masculine and all that stuff and just could, you know, just had it, you know, and has it and yeah, and helped me, you know,
like you guys know, you know, you can't do it on your own, you know, you need somebody to set you up. For sure. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. But Michael, your ability to find material or material find you and casts and directors that find you
and you find like, your career is just like, I don't, and I don't wanna embarrass you, but like Willie said, but your ability to jump from comedy to drama so seamlessly for so long, your run, your relevancy, is just, it's been going for so long and continuing on this great escalating pitch that I hope you're as proud of as you deserve to be because you're just an incredible actor
that knows how to make people laugh when you're playing a part and make people cry. Like you're not a comic, you're not a, you know, like, so I just, I, can you talk a little bit about how, I wanna ask you to explain how you see yourself, but how do you, what attracts you to certain stuff? What's your goal, you know? Yeah, well, I will speak about it,
but I kinda wanna stop, because that's just too good. I'll leave it at that. Well, thank you, first of all. Just can't label you, you know, and that takes a lot of fun. Yeah, okay, well, let's start with that. So first of all, let's thank good fortune and all that.
I don't believe in luck, I've never believed in luck, but I believe in good fortune. I do, I say that, dude, I literally say the same. Really? Yes. Because it's true. It's true. I say I'm fortunate, I'm not lucky, I'm fortunate.
No man, you know why? You earned what you, all three, a lot of us, we all earned it. We worked our asses off to do it all three, a lot of us, we all earned it. We worked our asses off to direct. There's a lot of talented people out there that luck plays a huge part of it because if everybody who was talented got the jobs, there wouldn't be any left.
I mean, luck plays a big part of it, so we're all appreciative of that. But I'm grateful, I'm grateful, grateful. So there was the only plan, and by the way, I'm breathing rarefied air right now. I realize that there's, I don't know how many other guys, or I saw Jeff the other day at Bridges, who lives over the mountain range here.
Another one, exactly like that. Yeah, he, you know, I was saying, you know, there's not many of us doing this, and I wanna keep doing it, but I wanna keep doing it. I always wanted to do it how I wanted to do it. I know that sounds arrogant and kind of selfish, but I just knew I'd be happiest that way. And so every time I had a television show
that got canceled, which was two of them, three of them, I guess, I could not tell you how happy I was because I felt freer to move on to the next thing. So if I had a strategy, and I don't know that it was a strategy, it was only this. Right after night shift, there were some things offered to me. And when I think back, I go, wow, that took a fairly sizable set of balls. I said, no, I knew I wanted to do the Mr.
Mr. Mom, but then there are a couple others that I thought, I don't know, like all three of you I'm sure, I would think, you say, but I really have a pretty big imagination and I'm curious about a lot of things and I'd like to play other things, I'd like to explore other things, I'd like to see, and if it doesn't work, then I know at least I have this for a few years. I can maybe grind out five, six, eight years of me being that guy. And I thought, but I think what will happen is people are going to get very bored very quickly with this kind of guy they saw in night shift, etc. And so I said, Well, then let me lay down something early and see if that works, because that will potentially open up a wider
range for me. And I don't know if this is gonna do it. But that was the only conscious thing. The other the other is you just trust your gut. And so I made certain decisions early on, I was told,'t do Clean and Sober, don't do Pacific Heights, don't do a lot of things. And I said, yeah, but I wanna do those things and I wanna lay it down. So I passed up certain movies that turned out to be great movies
and I wanna talk about them, but they turned out to be great things. And I probably in retrospect, one or two of those probably should have, but I was fearful that, look, I always feel like, and this is my own, I'm sorry, need to talk to somebody about this, because I always feel, man, if I'm in two movies a year,
people are gonna go, enough already, we are so friggin' sick of you, you know, we just, like enough. And so I had that and that's not a healthy thing. But I just wanted to lay down the potential possibility that, well, wait a minute now, I don't know what to do with him. And the risk is, as you guys know,
well, that could be dangerous. And I just rolled the dice, because I always bet on me, don't ask me why, but I do. But you also had this great combination between leading man and character actor. That's what I, for me, just as a consumer of you, a fan, you never really took the junk food, the celebrity stuff. You always were just playing an actor.
You were either a character actor or a leading man and sort of this great ratio between both and comedy and drama. And then for my money, like this incredible validation in Birdman, at a moment where a filmmaker and an actor come together in this incredible little recipe between the two that you wouldn't normally put together. And then, like, I don't know,
there's been a few combinations like that that was just so exciting to see that combination. And then, of course, the film itself and the concept of the film as well. Just everything coming together and just a rocket ship. And it was so exciting for me to see. Just that the story in the community and then also just the film itself.
Well, but also Michael, like, you know, as Jason sort of said, you kind of defied genre in that you couldn't be put in a thing. You got to be a movie star on your own terms. You got to kind of... You know, in a time where there really aren't really movie stars in that way anymore. I mean, there are, but it's different. But you were in like the height of the movie star era,
and yet you were able to kind of... Think about it in that year, you were talking about doing stuff you wanted to do. In 1988, you did Beetlejuice and Clean and Sober. Now you wanna talk about two movies on different ends of the spectrum, okay? And then the next year, you did the first film, and we're gonna get into Batman in a second, because it's the one thing that I feel
a real kinship with you about. But you were part of a lot of firsts, like Will's kinda saying, like Mr. Mom, nobody was doing a comedy like that, you were the first one to do a comedy kinda like that. And then Beetlejuice, and then Batman, like you were the first to do a lot of things, is that something you look for, like in scripts?
Well I was gonna say, so you do that, in that one year you do Beetlejuice in Clean and Sober, what was that year like for you? And it- You made your agent look fantastic that year. for you? And it- Your agent must've, you made your agent look fantastic that year. Yeah. You know?
我是说，你做到了，在短短那一年里你演了《阴间大法师》和《清醒梦/酒醒时分》，那几年对你来说是什么样的？而且——那年你让你的经纪人看起来太棒了。对你来说？而且——你的经纪人一定，那年你让你的经纪人看起来棒极了。是啊。你知道吗？
Yeah, exactly. And meanwhile, that's right, and at the time, that's not what happened, as you guys know, it didn't happen that way. Tim sought me out, because we had, he sought me, he said that I'd like to talk to that guy. And so, yeah, that, you know, and I will also credit Elvis Mitchell, whom I'm actually going to speak with later. And Elvis ended up working for me and my partner Harry
对，没错。与此同时，没错，当时根本不是那样的，正如你们所知，事情不是那样发展的。蒂姆主动来找我，因为我们有，他找了我，他说过我想跟那家伙谈谈。所以，是的，而且我也要感谢埃尔维斯·米切尔，我实际上稍后会和他交谈。埃尔维斯最后为我和我的搭档哈里
for a couple of years because we read this guy, we thought he was, we just dug what he was about and liked him. And he worked for us for a minute. And I credit Elvis, I don't think there was, I don't know what the award was. It And I credit Elvis, I don't think there was, I don't know what the award was, it was either New York, I don't know what it was, New York Film Critics Award, there was something, they didn't have an event, and Elvis kind of said, excuse me,
工作了几年，因为我们听了这个家伙，我们觉得他，我们就是喜欢他的风格和为人。他在我们这里干了一阵子。我得感谢埃尔维斯，我不觉得有什么，我不知道那是什么奖。它而且我得感谢埃尔维斯，我不觉得有什么，我不知道那是什么奖，要么是纽约，我不知道那是什么，纽约影评人协会奖，有什么东西，他们没有举办活动，埃尔维斯就有点像是说，不好意思，
what Will just said basically, and then they said, okay, sure, we'll give it to him, and then there was, I have somewhere a piece of paper or something but That didn't come via that came from Tim asking about me about me wanting to meet me about beer juice through David Geffen and The clean and sober thing came and that was another thing that people said you don't wanna you don't want to do that
基本上就是威尔刚刚说的话，然后他们就说，好吧，当然，我们把奖给他，然后就有了，我某个地方有一张纸或者别的什么，但这并不是通过大卫·格芬找到蒂姆、蒂姆问起我、我想见蒂姆关于《阴间大法师》的事得来的，而《清醒梦》那件事出现了，那是另一件人们说“你不想演那个、你不想演那个”的事。
That's not my agent literally at the time said I don't't want to do that. My agent literally at the time said, I don't think you should do that. And I said, yeah, I'm pretty sure I should, just because I want to. This is a really well-written script. You guys know this. I mean, it's hard to redefine something that's, the writing will drive everything ultimately right now, whether it comes together, that's another story.
那不是我的经纪人当时字面意思上说我不想演那个。我的经纪人当时字面意思上说，我觉得你不应该演那个。我说，不，我很确定我应该演，就因为我想演。这是一个非常棒的剧本。你们都知道。我是说，要重新定义一个东西很难，剧本最终会决定一切，至于它能不能成那是另一回事。
But so, I'll run through this. I'm sorry. And so that in one year, I didn't plan any of that. That just happened. I just said, man, this guy, Tim Burton, he's something I just I don't know what he is. I just know for sure he's something. And I, when he tried to explain to me, I said, they said, what do you think I said, I don't know what it is. I don't know what I don't understand that. And I like that guy. And he said, he wants to talk to you. Will you just give me another one? I go, Yeah, all right. I'll go meet him again. And I go talk to him. And I
但总之，我顺着这个说。对不起。所以在一年里，我根本没计划过这些。事情就那么发生了。我只是觉得，天哪，这个叫蒂姆·波顿的家伙，他很特别，我只是——我不知道他算什么。我只知道他绝对很特别。当他试图向我解释时，我说，他们问我觉得怎么样，我说，我不知道那是什么。我不知道，我搞不懂。但我喜欢那家伙。他说，他想跟你谈谈。你能不能再给我一个？我说，行，好吧。我再去见他一次。然后我去跟他谈，我
said, Yeah, well, I'm still the same. I still don't understand. He I say this about Tim, who I freaking love. I would say in his life, he is a declarative sentence with a subject, a verb, and then a period at the end. I'd say he's completed maybe eight, maybe eight declarative simple sentences. He just doesn't think like that.
说，好吧，我还是老样子。我还是不懂。我对蒂姆——我超级爱他——这样评价过：我觉得在生活中，他就是一个带有主语、谓语最后加个句号的陈述句。我觉得他大概写完了八个、大概八个陈述简单句。他根本不是那种思维方式。
He's not that guy, you know? And so I meet him and I go, okay, I'm getting closer. Then he said two things to me and I went, all right, I think this guy's worth it. So I said, give me a minute. And I went home and I started thinking about it and he said a couple things and I asked for wardrobe from every period of time to go to my house. I was renting this house, the time was empty, I didn't know
他不是那种人，你知道吗？所以我去见他，我说，好吧，我更了解一点了。然后他对我说两件事，我就想，好吧，我觉得这家伙值得。所以我说，给我一分钟。我回家开始琢磨，他说了一些话，我要求把各个历史时期的戏服都送到我家。我当时在租这栋房子，那时候里面是空的，我不知道
furniture and I just started hand picking stuff and then I, there's something about that I found kind of spooky and creepy about like bad teeth and a semi-broken nose and a walk and a... And I said, what about... And I just started going to work and I said, you know what, there's something about this guy, I really dig him, fuck it, I don't know, I don't know, does this work? And so that happened, and then Clean It Sober was just another script, it wasn't like I said... Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
家具的事，我开始亲手挑选东西，然后我——我发现那种坏牙齿、半断的鼻梁、走路的姿态，还有……让我觉得有点诡异和阴森。我说，如果……然后我开始开工，我说，你知道吗，这家伙身上有种特质，我真的很喜欢他，管他的，我不知道，我不知道，这行得通吗？所以事情就这样发生了，然后《清醒梦》只是另一个剧本，并不是说我说……等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。
Okay. The character of Beelgeuse, first of all, half the movie you're in like old timey prison garb. Right. And you've got this fucking, you've got like mascara on that covers half your face. And your hair is sticking up and you've got this voice and you go, yeah, yeah, yeah, say where you are. Yeah, it's so good. And you fucking, and I'm like, you want to talk about taking a big fucking swing
好吧。《阴间大法师》这个角色，首先，电影有一半时间你都穿着那种老式的囚服。对吧。而且你画着这种他妈的、遮住你半边脸的睫毛膏。你的头发竖得老高，你用那种声音说话，你说，对，对，对，说说你在哪。对，太棒了。你他妈的，我就觉得，你想谈谈那种孤注一掷的疯狂尝试吗
Oh, yeah, I mean, how do you go? How do you show up day one? Are they like, okay guys, let's rehearse All right, we're gonna block the scene. I'm like and you come I go Say it's your day. Yeah What the fuck is good? What's this guy doing? I mean, it's a lot and it fucking you nail you drilled, you drilled it in a way that you couldn't even. Did you preview that for Tim before the first rehearsal and the first day? No, that's very insightful, Will, because you're right. That's what, no, I didn't, and that was the beauty of,
哦，是的，我是说，你怎么做到的？第一天你怎么亮相的？他们会说，好吧伙计们，我们排练吧，好吧，我们来走位。我说，然后你来了，我说，说，今天是你的日子。yeah。这他妈的算怎么回事？这家伙在干嘛？我是说，这太疯狂了，而你他妈的、你拿下了，你以一种你甚至无法想象的方式搞定了。在第一次排练和第一天之前，你给蒂姆试看过这个吗？不，威尔，这很有洞察力，因为你说得对。那是，不，我没有，而那正是……的美妙之处，
and is the beauty of working with him. You're really just making stuff. Like, let's go make stuff, you know? And so, we talked, and no one was paying attention. The budget was too small, and no one was paying attention. The budget was small and no one was paying attention. And we were down in Raleigh Studios. And I said, okay, I don't know. Here's what's weird about this.
也是和共事的美妙之处。你其实就是在凭空创作。就像，我们去创作吧，你知道吗？所以，我们聊了聊，当时根本没人关注。预算太小了，根本没人关注。预算很小，根本没人关注。我们在罗利制片厂。我说，好吧，我不知道。这最诡异的地方在于：
Think of this. We never tested it. We never tested it. I said, here's what I wanna do. It's like he stuck his finger in a thing, he starts here and he goes up from there. It's never like, there's no arc. Yeah, right, right.
想想看。我们从来没试过。我们从来没试过。我说，这是我想做的：就像他把手指插进一个东西里，从这儿开始，然后从那往上飙。从来不是说，没有那种起承转合。对，没错，没错。
He just goes from 10 to 15. Right, right. And it never, and it never, and I said, and I don't know why, I don't have an actor's explanation for any of that shit. Like the great thing about this thing is you never could say my character wouldn't do that. Right, right, right.
他直接从10飙到15。对，没错。而且从不，而且从不，我说，我也不知道为什么，对于所有这些狗屁东西，我没有什么演员式的解释。就像这东西最棒的一点在于，你绝不会说“我的角色不会那么做”。对，没错，没错。
The rule, there are no rules. There are no rules. The freedom was unbelievable. So Will, that's insightful because I go, Tim had the suit, Tim had the eyes, Tim had the pale makeup, and he said something to me about he's from all different. He appears out of time, you know, in the 20s and the 18s. There's no he's not connected at any time or anything.
规矩就是，没有规矩。没有规矩。那种自由度简直难以置信。所以威尔，这很有洞察力，因为我说，蒂姆有那套西装，蒂姆有那些眼睛，蒂姆有苍白的妆容，他跟我说过他是从不同的时代来的。他超脱于时代之外，你知道的，出现在20年代和18年代。没有，他跟任何时代都没有关联。
He might go underground for years until he's released. So I said, underground, I said, how about mold? Let's do some mold up the face, you know? And then and then I said, OK, you know, the hair is like it has to Stick all the way out and but the striped suit was Tim's vision. He started showing me pictures of all his stuff and so on that day When I showed up I went I don't know Here we go. Right and as soon as I walk the first scene you can see him
他可能会在地下待好几年，直到被放出来。所以我说，地下，我说，霉菌怎么样？我们在脸上搞点霉菌吧，你知道吗？然后然后我说，好吧，你知道，头发必须竖得老高，但条纹西装是蒂姆的构想。他开始给我看他所有东西的照片，所以在当天的拍摄中，当我现身时，我心想，我不知道。就这样吧。对，而且只要我一出场拍第一场戏，你就能看到他
Here we go. And as soon as I walk in the first scene, you can see him, his eyes get big and he lights up and he goes, yes. And then, you know, it's the ultimate yes and, because he'd go, oh, I didn't know we were gonna do that. Hold on a minute, if you're gonna do that, let me show you something. See when you go up there, this is what that's gonna,
就这样吧。而且只要我一出场拍第一场戏，你就能看到他，他的眼睛睁得老大，双眼放光，说道：没错。然后，你知道的，这就是终极的“对，而且”（即兴接话技巧），因为他会说，哦，我不知道我们要那样演。等一下，如果你要那样演，让我给你看个东西。你看，当你走到那儿的时候，这就将，
he had to explain to me what was gonna happen. And I went, oh, I think I get it. Because of the visual effects? Yeah, because of the visual effects. Would happen later, yeah? Yes, yes, yes. And also. Fuck man, dude, you're out on,
他不得不向我解释接下来会发生什么。然后我心想，哦，我大概懂了。因为视觉效果吗？对，因为视觉效果。那是之后才有的，对吧？是的，是的，是的。而且还有。
I love this so much. Out on a ledge. I love the idea that you're out on a fucking ledge and you don't know where you're fucking going. That to me is my- And then give a shit. And don't get, that's my fucking dream come true, man. I know, I know.
他妈的，老兄，你这是在，我太喜欢这个了。如履薄冰。我太喜欢那种如履薄冰、根本不知道自己要去向何方的感觉了。对我来说，那是我的——而且根本不在乎。而且别管那些，那是我他妈的梦想成真，老兄。我知道，我知道。
It's so fun to talk to you guys about this because there's there's I'm with three people who know Kind of know what I'm talking about, but then you land it into the then you go to clean and sober Exactly, which is the most like no tricks. No makeup. No wardrobe It's just people not hiding being raw and like I'm being honest Mike Tyson walking in with trunks and two box and gloves Yeah How many people over the years have come up to you and told you that clean and sober had a profound effect on their life? and like, I'm being honest. It's Mike Tyson walking in with trunks and two box of gloves. How many people over the years have come up to you
跟你们聊这些太有趣了，因为有——我和三个稍微懂我在说什么的人在一起，但随后你把话题落到了——然后你转向了《清醒梦》。没错，那是最没有花招的。没有化妆。没有服装。那只是人们不再隐藏，展现出最真实的状态，就像迈克·泰森穿着拳击短裤和两只拳击手套走进来。 yeah 这么多年来，有多少人走到你面前，告诉你《清醒梦》对他们的人生产生了深远的影响？ and like, I'm being honest. It's Mike Tyson walking in with trunks and two box of gloves. How many people over the years have come up to you
and told you that clean and sober had a profound effect on their life? Lots, and boy, that means something to me. You know, so I say this, I don't care what people think. I'm so blessed that I get to do some things that every once in a while, that'll happen. How many people have that job?
告诉你《清醒梦》对他们的人生产生了深远的影响？很多人，天哪，这对我意义重大。你知道，所以我总是说，我不在乎别人怎么想。我太幸运了，偶尔能拍出一些能产生这种影响的作品。谁能拥有这样一份工作？
You know, a lot of people would like that job. I am that job. That's why I did worth. Yeah, that's why I did you know my life You know my life and you go you got to do these things if you got the heartbreaker You know, you know, you've been given this this Given this thing, you know, yeah, I earned it but I've been also given it So so if you can do throw everybody a solid fucking do it, you know've been also given it. So if you can do, throw everybody a solid, fucking do it, you know? And then go make some money.
你知道，很多人都想干这工作。我就是干这工作的。这就是为什么我拍了《利益风暴》。对，这就是为什么我拍了——你知道我的人生。你知道我的人生，你会觉得，只要你有那颗心，你就得去做这些事。你知道，你知道，你被赋予了——被赋予了这东西，你知道， yeah，我靠自己赢得的，但我也被赋予了它。所以，如果你能做到，就顺手帮大家一把，他妈的去做吧，你知道吗？然后去赚点钱。
So you're speaking of which, speaking of making money, you go in 1989, you once again team up with Tim Burton and you do Batman. Yeah. And that is the you do Batman. Yeah. And that is the fucking game changer. Yeah. That's the game changer of game changer. And I mean, in a lot of ways,
所以说到这个，说到赚钱，1989年，你再次与蒂姆·波顿合作，拍摄了《蝙蝠侠》。 yeah。这就是你——你演了《蝙蝠侠》。 yeah。这才是他妈的颠覆游戏规则之作。 yeah。那是彻底改变游戏规则的颠覆之作。我是说，从很多方面来说，
you doing that allowed me to make some money. Yeah. So. Oh yeah. All right. So I guess I kind of fucking owe you, dude. A little bit. A little bit. A little bit. A little bit. A little bit.
你演那个让我赚到了一些钱。对。所以。哦，是啊。好吧，那我大概真他妈欠你的，老兄。多少有一点。一点点。一点点。一点点。一点点。
A little bit. A little bit. A little bit. You did the first I Am Batman. By the way, I'll give you my business manager's address. Just Venmo. Just do Venmo. Yeah, just do Venmo.
一点点。一点点。一点点。你演了第一部《我是蝙蝠侠》。顺便说一句，我把我的商务经理的地址给你。直接用Venmo转账就行。就用Venmo。对，直接用Venmo。
Just straight Venmo. And Mike, I just got out of high school when that came out, when Batman came out, and I was like, wait, the guy from Night Shift that I've seen a million times in Mr. Mob, he's Batman? Like, and then I didn't- Take the look of your face again. No, but wait, hang on, wait for it.
就直接Venmo。迈克，那部电影上映时我刚高中毕业，当《蝙蝠侠》上映时，我就想，等等，那个我在《午夜场》里见过无数次、在《好家伙》里的家伙，他演蝙蝠侠？就像，然后我没有——再摆出你刚才那个表情。不，等等，等等，接着看。
And then you saw, I even saw the trailer, I was like, oh my God, I can't, I mean, nailed it in the trailer. I remember seeing the poster for it. I was like, oh my God. Do you remember seeing the poster, just the symbol of the Batman, and I was like, what? I was like, what the fuck is this?
然后你看到，我甚至看了预告片，我就想，天哪，我不能——我是说，预告片太神了。我还记得看到它的海报。我当时想，天哪。你还记得看到那张海报吗，只有蝙蝠侠的标志，我就想，什么？我当时想，这他妈到底是什么？
So I'm about to give some credit to Tim for going, yeah, that guy. And people went, what are you, out of your mind? And he went, no, that guy. So I don't think enough credit has been given to him. Me, I went, we had the meeting, he and I sat, he said, take this home and read it, tell me what you think, and I remember where I was sitting,
所以我得把功劳归于蒂姆，是他坚持“对，就是那家伙”。当时人们说：“你疯了吗？”他却说：“不，就是那家伙。”所以我觉得没有给予他足够的赞誉。至于我，我们开了会，我和他坐在一起，他说：“拿回去读读，告诉我你的想法。”我还记得我当时坐的地方，
where the window was, and he and I were talking, and I said, well, so here's what I think, but nobody's gonna do that. And he went, that's exactly right. And so he had to go to them and say, no, that guy, and to his credit, boy, you know, he changed everything. He changed everything. I could talk.
窗户在哪，我和他在聊天，我说，好吧，这就是我的想法，但没人会那样拍。而他却说：“这正是我想的。”所以他不得不去找高层说：“不，就要那个家伙。”不得不说，老兄，你知道的，他改变了一切。他改变了一切。我甚至可以说，
I mean, Marvel exists. All of it exists because of that movie dude. Yeah, yeah. A lot of people made a lot of money off me and Tim and Jack. Sean has nutted over a thousand times to Marvel movies because of that movie. Uh-huh, yeah.
我是说，漫威的存在。这一切的存在都是因为那部电影，老兄。 yeah， yeah。肖恩因为那部电影，为漫威电影高潮了上千次。嗯哼， yeah。
Right, a thousand nuts. There's that. Yeah, there's that. Yeah, you can't put a price on that. No, you can't put a price on that. But it did, it launched the, you know, and ever since then we've all been fucking under the tyranny of IP, but you know,
对，高潮了一千次。就是这样。 yeah，就是这样。这可真是无价之宝。不，这确实无价。但它确实开启了——你知道的，从那以后我们都他妈活在IP的暴政之下，但你知道的，
but you did start that. And it was, I stole that from somebody. But it's true, but you guys started it, you and Tim Burton, but you is the face, Tim is incredible obviously, like you said. Well and you kind of invented the whole, like Will just said, like the whole thing. Like the tone and the feel and the look and the everything. Yeah, there was humor to it, but it was also serious and there was action and it was dark.
不过确实是你开启了这一切。而且——我是从别人那偷来的这话。但这是事实，确实是你们开启的，你和蒂姆·波顿，但你是门面，当然蒂姆也很不可思议，正如你所说。嗯，而且你有点发明了整部电影的风格，就像威尔刚刚说的，整个基调。整个基调、氛围、视觉效果以及一切。对，里面有幽默元素，但它同时也很严肃，有动作戏，而且很黑暗。
Yeah. But you know, Will, there was very little humor in it. And, you know, maybe we can't No, but you had moments though, as Bruce Wayne. No, I mean in the original script, in the original script. Oh, really? Yes. And so, you know, maybe it's just an instinct But but there were scenes because even that man that pressure was on Tim's so big Pressure was on all of us. Mm-hmm, and you felt it every day, you know Studio people flying it, you know, because this was a big swing for every, but there wasn't, and I don't know if it's the instinct or not, you know, a gut feeling saying, well, wait a minute, you know, a lot of this kind of darkness, I mean, maybe, maybe, maybe not
yeah。但你知道，威尔，里面其实没多少幽默感。而且，也许我们不能——不，但你确实有几个时刻，作为布鲁斯·韦恩。不，我是说在原版剧本里，在原版剧本里。哦，真的吗？是的。所以，你知道，也许这只是一种直觉，但确实有那些场景，因为当时蒂姆面临的压力太大了。我们所有人身上都有压力。嗯哼，你每天都能感受到，你知道的，
so much. So so as an example, in that scene where the big long table where Vicki Vale comes over, and I'm having date and I'm so nervous, you know, and I go, do I tell her do I not tell her? I can't let her know, but I really like this woman and she's sitting there and she asked me about the room and I said, Tim, you know, it would be funny. And there were a couple of these moments. I said, you know, if he goes, yeah, yeah, yeah,
制片厂的人飞过来监督，你知道的，因为这对所有人来说都是一次巨大的冒险，但并没有——我不知道这算不算直觉，是一种直觉告诉他：“嗯，等一下，你知道，这种黑暗色彩，也许，也许，没必要那么浓厚。”
and then he realizes, I don't think I've ever been in this room before, you know what I mean? Which says everything about the characters, you know? You go, who's this lonely guy? He's, you know, rambling around the house. Yeah, yeah. It's great, sort of like high-low of him. Yeah, I love that kind of stuff,
所以作为一个例子，在那场戏里，维姬·韦尔走过来的那张长餐桌旁，我在约会，我紧张得要死，你知道，我就想：我是该告诉她还是不该告诉她？我不能让她知道，但我真的很喜欢这个女人，她就坐在那儿，问我关于这个房间的事，我说：“蒂姆，你知道，这样会很有趣。”还有其他几个这样的时刻。我说，你知道，如果他说，好，好，好，
that kind of awareness of it, and not taking himself too seriously really in that moment, because there's a way that that could come across as a dick, and it wasn't, you got it. It all fell within the context of a guy who was really rich but his parents were murdered, but all that stuff, right? Yeah, and kind of a weird dude, you know, like a weird dude.
然后他意识到，我大概从来没在这个房间里待过，你知道我的意思吗？这把这个角色的一切都展现出来了，你知道吗？你会想：这个孤独的家伙是谁？他就在那儿，（漫无目的地）在房子里转悠。 yeah， yeah。太棒了，有点像他那种高雅与粗俗的结合。 yeah，我太喜欢那种东西了，
Very weird dude. And you know, but you, what was it like when that movie came out and it was, as you said, it was a big swing for everybody, big swing for you and your career, big swing for Tim Burton, big swing for the studio, they put a big swing for Tim Burton, a big swing for the studio, they put a lot of money into it, the books have been written about this movie and how it got made, et cetera.
那种自我觉知，而且那一刻真的没有把自己太当回事，因为有些演法可能会显得像个混蛋，但你没有，你拿捏住了。这一切都在一个很有钱但父母被谋杀的男人的背景下展开，所有这些元素，对吧？对，而且还是个怪人，你知道的，就像个怪人。
And when that movie comes out and it's a fucking smash hit, how many high fives, did you have to bandage your hand from the high fives? Or was it the opposite? Was it, oh, this is gonna be a level of exposure and responsibility now that could change things and it might not be comfortable? More that.
非常奇怪的家伙。你知道，但是你，当那部电影上映时，正如你所说，这对每个人来说都是一次巨大的冒险，对你和你的演艺生涯是一次巨大的冒险，对蒂姆·波顿是一次巨大的冒险，对制片厂是一次巨大的冒险，他们投入了巨资，关于这部电影以及它是如何拍成的等等，已经写了无数的书。
Jason, Jason immediately looks at the negative. Or was it that? Now I'm obligated to go and say thank people for paying money. I have junkets I have to go to. Now all of a sudden, now I've gotta talk to my business manager. It's good news, is it good news?
当那部电影上映并且大获成功时，有多少击掌，你的手是不是因为击掌太多而需要包扎？还是说恰恰相反？是不是，哦，现在将有一种曝光度和责任感，这可能会改变现状，而且可能不会让人觉得舒服？更偏向后者。
It's good news for you. Now did you guys know, did you guys know about the chemistry would work like Jason Brink is, you know, he's neat, everyone's trying to do what he just did. Did you guys go, oh fuck, that's why we hired the guy. Just bring in a dork. That's why we, yeah, it's bring him in. Well we've had the good fortune, guys, I'm gonna say of being friends for 20 years.
对你来说这是个好消息。话说你们知道吗，你们知道化学反应会像杰森·布林克那样运作吗，你知道的，他很干练，每个人都在试图做他刚刚做过的事。你们当时有没有想过，“哦，操，难怪我们雇了这家伙。只要招个书呆子就行了。”这就是为什么我们，是的，把他招来。好吧，各位，我有幸能说我们做了20年的朋友。
So we knew. Don't touch it. Yeah, we have a good little dance with these guys. It's like the guys on TBS, you know, Charles Barkley and those guys. Someone just needs to say to them, don't touch it. Don't touch it, just don't mess with it. I love those guys.
所以我们心知肚明。别碰它。是的，我们和这些家伙合作得非常默契。就像TBS电视台的那些人，你知道的，查尔斯·巴克利和他们那一伙。总得有人对他们说，别碰它。别碰它，就是别去瞎搞。我很喜欢他们。
Yeah. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. But did you, you must have, was it just, was it not what Jason was saying? Did you feel an obligation? No, I was going there, I'd like that, actually. Yeah, you were thinking about the deal
没错。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。但你当时肯定有，难道不是因为杰森说的话吗？你当时觉得自己有义务吗？不，我要去那儿，其实我还挺喜欢那样的。对，你当时在考虑
you already struck for the sequel. No, you woke up and you're like, did you buy a Ferrari? What the fuck? Did you do that? Got a tattoo a Batman tattoo That's true, you know, I actually did investigate getting a Ferrari one time. Yes, I actually did And I and I remember, I'm too lazy for the amount of work and effort I'm gonna have to put into this.
你已经为续集谈妥的片酬。不，你醒来的时候会想，你买了一辆法拉利？搞什么鬼？你居然买了这个？还文了一个蝙蝠侠文身。确实，你知道的，我其实真的曾经考虑过买一辆法拉利。是的，我真的考虑过。而且我记得，因为需要付出的工作和努力太多，我觉得自己太懒了。
I'm just too lazy. You mean the clutch and the stick, right? Yeah, well, not that so much, but like, where do I, do I have to be careful? Where can I really drive it? Is this really worth it? I'm blessed that I don't need a lot of stuff because I don't have,
我就是太懒了。你是说离合器和手动挡吧？对，倒不是那个问题，而是像，我在哪儿？我得小心翼翼吗？我到底能在哪里真正开它？这真的值得吗？我很庆幸自己不需要太多物质上的东西，因为我没有……
I'm just lucky that I don't need a lot of stuff. I'm just not so cool. I I don't need a lot of stuff. You know, I'm not so cool. I just don't have an interest in it. I love that you're thinking through the practicality of a Ferrari. Yeah, I know. I'm going, well, you can't valet it. Like, what do you do? Is it good on ice?
我很幸运自己不需要太多东西。我只是没那么酷。我不需要太多东西。你知道的，我没那么酷。我只是对这些不感兴趣。我很喜欢你居然在权衡一辆法拉利的实用性。对啊，我知道。我在想，好吧，你不能把它交给代客泊车。那你怎么办？它在冰面上好开吗？
All of a sudden, I'm the least interesting, most unfun guy. Oh, I don't know if this is practical. I'm going to put my clubs. There's no backseat. Oh, I don't know if this is practical You must have been elated and it must have felt like a good vindicated now look you'd had a lot of success before but This was like a different. This was a different thing. I bet I'd let myself enjoy it. It was global You let yourself enjoy it. Yeah, and and also what Jason? Called the downer. Let's just refer to it. No, and a little bit of that, say, whoa, this is a lot.
突然之间，我就成了最没趣、最无聊的人。哦，我不知道这实不实用。我要把高尔夫球杆放哪。连个后座都没有。哦，我不知道这实不实用。你当时一定欣喜若狂，一定觉得扬眉吐气、沉冤得雪了，现在看看，虽然你以前也取得过很大的成功，但这完全不同。这是另一种不同的体验。我敢说我让自己好好享受了。这是全球性的。
You know, it's not, I don't love this kind of stuff. Yeah, and sometimes knowing you, knowing who you are now and all your success with all of the unbelievable, your resume is just one of the most impressive ever. It really is. It's just incredible. I always, you know, you don't think about, oh, that guy probably had, he had an audition.
你让自己好好享受了。对，而且正如杰森所说的“扫兴时刻”。我们姑且这么称呼它吧。不，还有一点就是，你会觉得，“哇，这阵仗太大了。”你知道的，这不是，我其实不太喜欢这种事。对，有时候了解你，了解现在的你以及你所取得的所有成功，还有那些不可思议的成就，你的履历绝对是史上最令人印象深刻的之一。真的太惊人了。我总是觉得，你知道的，你不会去想，“哦，那家伙以前可能也去过，他曾有过一次试镜。”
Like, I just see you as a movie star, but when you're younger, you had an audition and start out, you know, just like all the rest of us. And it's hard to imagine you walking into a room. What made you, didn't you grow up in, where did you grow up? Right outside of Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania. And so what got you to LA? Like, what made you, didn't you grow up in, where did you grow up? Right outside of Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania. And so what got you to LA?
就像，我只把你当成一个电影明星，但当你更年轻的时候，你也经历过试镜，也是从底层开始的，你知道的，就像我们所有人一样。很难想象你走进一个房间时的样子。是什么让你，你不是在……你在哪里长大的？宾夕法尼亚州匹兹堡的郊外。那是什么让你去了洛杉矶？比如说，是什么让你，你不是在……你在哪里长大的？宾夕法尼亚州匹兹堡的郊外。那是什么让你去了洛杉矶？
Like what made you wanna do it? Well, boy, we could go, let me make it. We have 10 minutes left. Okay. Okay. For this one answer. Okay. Okay, right.
就像是什么促使你想去做的？好吧，天哪，我们可以继续……让我来说。我们还剩10分钟。好吧。好吧。就为了回答这一个问题。好吧。好吧，对。
Yeah, I just should've a couple of times, what's your explanation? No, no. I'm kidding, I'm totally, we just should have a couple of times. What's your next question? No, no. I'm kidding. We have an hour. Whatever you want. I was this kid who started to get very interested in, I thought, could a person do this? And yeah, because I come from so not that background except my funny family, my funny
对，我本来只该说几次的，你的解释是什么？不，不。我开玩笑的，我完全……我们本该说几次的。你的下一个问题是什么？不，不。我开玩笑的。我们有一个小时呢。随你便。我就是那种开始对一件事产生浓厚兴趣的孩子，我在想，一个人真的能做到这一点吗？是的，因为我的背景完全跟这不沾边，除了我那风趣的家庭，我风趣的
brothers and sisters, and a big family and youngest. So there's that, right? So when I went to school, I was curious because my friends and I were, the guys I hung with tightly, and some young women at the time, were funny, and I'd like to be around them, and I knew what my taste was in terms of, and so I was not a theater kid,
兄弟姐妹们，一个大家庭，而我是老幺。所以就是这样，对吧？所以当我上学的时候，我很好奇，因为我和我的朋友们——那些我走得很近的家伙，还有当时的一些年轻女性——都很有趣，我很喜欢和他们待在一起，而且我知道自己对于……的品味是什么样的，所以我并不是那种戏剧特长生，
however, I did take a couple theater classes, so I was clearly curious about this and I was not very good, I don't think. I auditioned for a play, I got a little role in a play in school, didn't really do anything for me. And then I dropped out of school to make some money to go back to school. And in the interim, I was doing this play in Pittsburgh, Sticks and Bones, and at the same time working at the PBS station where I do everything and everything.
不过，我确实上了几节戏剧课，所以我显然对这个很感兴趣，而且我觉得我其实演得不是很好。我去为一个话剧试镜，在学校的一部戏里演了一个小角色，对我来说其实没什么实质性的帮助。然后我辍学去赚点钱，好准备重返学校。在此期间，我在匹兹堡排练这部话剧《木棍与骨头》（Sticks and Bones），同时还在PBS电视台打杂，什么活都干。
And at the same time while I was in school, I was really into The Lampoon, and I was really into everything funny. And I was just, and so I started writing, and I thought, I don't know if I can even do this other thing if I ever try it, maybe I could write this. You're just a kid trying to figure things out, right?? Yeah, so I said well, I'm kind of liking this I just trusted myself and I said, you know what?
与此同时，当我在学校的时候，我真的很喜欢《哈佛讽刺家》杂志（The Lampoon），我真的很迷恋所有有趣的事物。我当时只是……所以开始写作，我在想，如果我尝试一下的话，我都不知道自己能不能做好这另一行，也许我可以写剧本。你当时只是个试图搞清楚状况的孩子，对吧？？对，所以我说，嗯，我好像挺喜欢这个的。我只是相信了自己，然后我说，你知道吗？
This is this is either gonna happen or not happen. So I started to go to New York Where I was about to move and at the last minute I went to California thinking I'd only stay there for a summer and I was writing and I started performing standup and doing a play and the standup thing worked in New York like that off the bat. I mean, when I say worked, it didn't work. It worked in that I got asked back the first time I showed up and that's a big deal.
这件事要么成功，要么失败。所以我开始前往纽约，我当时正准备搬到那里，结果在最后一分钟我去了加州，本以为只会在那儿待一个夏天。我当时一边写作，一边开始表演单口喜剧，还参演了一部话剧。单口喜剧在纽约一炮而红，进展十分顺利。我的意思是，当我说“顺利”时，其实并不是指大获成功，而是指我第一次登台后就被邀请再次出演，这可是件大事。
So you did that and I went, I really love this because it was theater. To get to the auditioning part, so now I'm gonna go to California and I went I really love this because it was theater. To get to the auditioning part, so now I go to California and I'm gonna do this real fast and I'm sleeping on floors like everybody else and crashing with buddies and working in restaurants and doing all the things, parking cars, doing everything everybody does. The thing that turned it around in terms of the audition process was I was an okay auditioner but what and I tell when young people ask me,
所以你做了那个，然后我想，我真的很喜欢这个，因为它是戏剧。说到试镜部分，现在我要去加州了，我想我真的很喜欢这个，因为它是戏剧。说到试镜部分，现在我要去加州了，我打算快点把这事搞定。像其他人一样睡在地板上，借宿在哥们儿家里，在餐馆打工，做所有那些别人都在做的事——泊车、干各种大家都在干的杂活。在试镜流程方面真正扭转局面的事情是，我其实是个还算可以的试镜者，但正如我经常对年轻人说的那样，
I tell them this all the time, forget I want, I want, I need, forget, throw that out, you're fucked. You have the job, the job is for the next 15 minutes, you're at work. The audition is the job, that's the gig. So you got to go to work today for 15 minutes. You know, it's excruciating, it's a horrible setup.
当年轻演员问我时，我总是告诉他们：忘了“我想要”、我想要这个、我需要这个，统统忘掉，扔掉它们，你就死定了。你现在已经得到这份工作了，这份工作就是接下来的15分钟，你正在上班。试镜就是工作，这就是你的差事。所以你今天得去上班15分钟。你知道的，这简直是一种折磨，是一个糟糕透顶的设定。
There's nothing good about it, but that was the, once I said, I'm not gonna look at this like, I gotta get this, I turned the corner where I said, you know what, man, I felt pretty good today about what I did, so I'm just gonna look at it like, at 3.30, out at MTM Studios or wherever I was gonna be. Yeah, I'm going, at Radford, I'm going gonna look at it like at 3.30 out at MTM studios or wherever I was gonna be. Radford, yeah.
这里面没什么好事，但那就是……一旦我说“我不能把这看作是我必须得到这个”，我就转折了。我当时说：“你知道吗，老兄，我今天对自己做的事感觉挺好的。”所以我就把它看作是：下午3点30分，在MTM工作室或者无论我要去的哪个地方。是的，我在雷德福（Radford），我要把它看作是下午3点30分在MTM工作室或者无论我要去的哪个地方。雷德福，是的。
Yeah, I'm going to Radford. I'm going to work. And so I thought, yep, get ready to go to work. What a great approach. My job only lasted 20 minutes and then I went to my regular job and I said, I don't know, fuck it, Graham. Freed me up, totally freed me up.
对，我要去雷德福。我要去上班了。所以我心想，没错，准备去上班吧。多棒的心态啊。我的工作只持续了20分钟，然后我就去干我的常规工作了。我心想，管他呢，去他的吧，格雷姆。这彻底解放了我，完全解放了我。
Of course it did and I like the idea of also telling that to young actors because people, they ask me for advice all the time, and I always say, you know, fuck off. So now I have something that I can say I came up with. Get that camera out of my face. Who the fuck, who gave you, my parents know your parents, shut the fuck. No, but that is such great advice.
当然是这样，我也很喜欢把这个观点告诉年轻演员，因为人们总是向我征求建议，而我总是说：“滚蛋吧。”所以现在我终于有了一句可以说是我自己原创的话了。把那摄像机拿开我的脸。到底是谁……谁给你的……我父母认识你父母，给老子闭嘴。不，但这真的是个绝佳的建议。
You know, I think the other thing is, it kind of falls in the same line of like, once you realize, once you get older and you've done a bit more in doing what we do, you start to, and you get to the other side and you have a chance to direct JB and produce stuff and whatever, you realize that they are looking to solve a problem, right? That they want somebody to come in.
你知道，我觉得另一件事是，它和刚才那个理念不谋而合：一旦你意识到，当你年纪渐长、在我们这行经历得更多一些时，你开始……当你走到另一端，有机会执导JB的戏并制作各种东西时，你会意识到，他们其实是想解决一个问题，对吧？他们希望有人能走进来。
They want, what you don't know as a young actor is- They're on your side. They're on your side. They want you to get this job. Because they- They got another character to cast. Yeah, because once I figured that out, and I was like, and I remember casting something
他们希望……作为一个年轻演员，你所不知道的是——他们是站在你这一边的。他们是站在你这一边的。他们希望你能得到这份工作。因为他们——他们还得去试镜另一个角色。对，因为一旦我明白了这一点，我就……我记得和米奇一起选角的时候，看到有人走进来，然后心里想：“哦，操，希望这家伙表现好点。”我以前还以为他们的态度是“哦？展示给我看看吧。”不，我们的想法是：“操，这这家伙太棒了。”对，我以前以为他们的态度是“哦？展示给我看看吧”，不。我们的想法是：“操，这家伙太棒了。”是的，我想完成这个勾选项。我想把那个选项勾掉。对，但当然啦，你们都是演员，
with Mitch and being like, and people coming in and going, oh fuck, I hope this dude's good, man. And I used to think that they're like, oh, show me. No, we were like, fuck it, this guy's great. Yeah, I I used to think that they're like, oh, show me, no. We were like, fuck it, this guy's great. Yeah, I wanna check the box. I wanna check that box. Yeah, but sure, you guys are actors,
所以你们很有同理心。你知道那种感觉是什么样的，对吧？所以，是的，你不会希望有什么……看着别人搞砸没有任何意义。哦，那简直是最糟的。不，也没有任何价值。哦，那简直糟透了。那他妈的是最糟糕的感觉。等等，我想聊聊……因为你知道的，
so you're sympathetic. You know what that feels like, right? So, yeah, you don't want something, there's no merit in watching somebody go down. Oh, it's the worst. No, there's no merit, too. Oh, it's the worst. It's the fucking worst feeling. Wait, I wanna talk about, because you know,
我想说第二季。但你做过……对不起，我只是想说，因为他刚刚在谈论试镜的经历，如果你不介意的话，就一秒钟。哦，对。让我想到了另一个话题。不，我开玩笑的。是吗？
I wanted to do a second. But you did, I'm sorry, I was just gonna say, because he was just talking about the auditioning shot, if you don't mind, just one second. Oh, yeah. Made me think of another subject. No, I'm just kidding. Do you?
是吗？是吗？不，既然我们聊到这个话题，就是那个……你刚才在谈论另一个……就是那个，你在谈论MTM的时候，你演过……我在开场白里可没开玩笑，你曾参演过玛丽·泰勒·摩尔（Mary Tyler Moore）的两部不同迭代作品，一部叫《玛丽》，另一部叫《玛丽秀》。
Do you? Do you? No, while we're on the subject, is that, and you were talking about this other, is that, and you were talking about MCM, you did, I wasn't kidding in my intro, you were on that two different iterations of the Mary Tyler, one called Mary, and the other called him Mary.
真的吗？《玛丽·泰勒·摩尔时刻》（Mary Tyler Moore Hour），是叫这个名字吗？对，对。和戴夫·莱特曼一起。和莱特曼。等等，什么？莱特曼拍完第一集就跑路了，对。我留了下来。
Really? Mary Tyler Moore Hour, is that what it was called? Yeah, yeah. With Dave Letterman. With Letterman. Wait, what? Letterman bailed after the first one, yeah. I stuck around.
太搞笑了。他们当时还在一个剧组里。我竟然不知道这件事。在1978年，迈克，是这样吗？等等，你和吉米·伯罗斯（Jimmy Burroughs）合作过吗？吉米·伯罗斯，等等，吉米·伯罗斯导演过——他导演了《玛丽·泰勒·摩尔时刻》。等等，杰森，你和我，
That's so funny. And they were in the fucking cast together. I didn't know that. In 1978, Mike, was that right? Wait, did you work with Jimmy Burroughs? Jimmy Burroughs, wait, Jimmy Burroughs directed- He directed Mary Tyler March. Wait, Jason, you and I,
你知道我最喜欢的几份工作之一是什么吗？我一直真的很喜欢加里·戈德堡（Gary Goldberg）。对，对，对。我一直都很喜欢他，是个好人，还有他的妻子，我记得是戴安娜。柯特妮两天前还在对赞不绝口，与此同时她也在夸奖你。哈，好吧，他给了我这个差事，这是我最喜欢的……
you know one of my favorite jobs ever? I always really liked Gary Goldberg. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And I always really liked him, good guy, and his wife, I remember Diana. Courtney actually was just singing his praises two days ago at the same time she was singing yours. Huh, well he gave me this gig that was one of my favorite,
我一会儿再跟你聊那个MTM的事情，但我做过的最喜欢的事情之一，就是我在……托尼·兰德尔（Tony Randall）曾短暂开过一个节目。他好像开过好几个节目。大概有很多节目吧。但他有个节目叫《托尼·兰德尔秀》，加里·戈德堡雇佣我是因为他看过我的表演。我想是他给了我这份工作。我可能也参加过试镜。
I'll talk to you about that MTM thing, but one of my favorite things I ever did was this character I did on... Tony Randall had a show for a minute. He had a couple of shows, I guess. Many shows, probably. But he had a thing called the Tony Randall Show, and Gary Goldberg hired me because he had seen me do something. I think he gave me the job. I might have auditioned.
但在夜校里，那个节目好像叫《埃德的夜校》，托尼·兰德尔在夜校教法律，而我扮演那种……你知道的，有点一根筋的角色，这种角色总是很有趣但又很难演——演蠢货这件事，能演得好的人其实没问题，而我演蠢货完全没有压力。不，这他妈就是我的本色……那正是你的拿手好戏。总之，我演了那个角色。顺便说一句，从观看托尼·兰德尔的表演中，我学到了很多关于喜剧的知识，因为他会亲自指导，
But at night school, it was called Ed's night school I think and Tony Randall taught law at a night school and I played this kind of dude you know and you know like kind of little dense which is always fun and hard to play like playing stupid as so well has no problem playing no it's my fucking it's right out of. That's your sweet spot. Anyway, so I played this thing and as an aside, I learned as much about comedy from watching Tony Randall because he would kind of direct
毕竟他懂的比谁都多。他的精确度是如此……而我当时还处于那种……我觉得，不，老兄，你知道的，要随性发挥。他的精确度是如此……而我当时还处于那种……我觉得，不，老兄，你知道的，要随性发挥。他的精确度是如此令人印象深刻，以至于我记得当时想：“哇，好好注意这个。”你知道的，关于时机、方法以及……这真是一次教育。所以，当我正在……当我正在做那个的时候，我显然已经把问题给忘光了，不过《玛丽·泰勒·摩尔秀》……然后那引发了后来的所有事情。所以莱特曼在第一季之后就退出惹，
because he knew more than anybody anyway. And his precision was so, and I was about, like I thought, no man, you know, freewheeling. His precision was so, and I was about, like I thought, no man, you know, freewheeling, his precision was so impressive that I remember going, whoa, pay attention to that. You know, where, you know, where and the how and the, you know, it was just really an education. So yeah, when I was, when I was doing that and I apparently have forgotten the question, but Mary Tellermore, so then that then that led to all that other stuff. So Letterman bailed after the first,
我们都以为这会是个不错的节目，而且她是一位非常棒的女士，我很喜欢她。那个组合里的那些家伙，也就是杰伊·塔苏斯（Jay Tarsus）和汤姆，那些人，他们都是其中一员。所以我们想，嗯，他们的资历真的很棒。但结果并不是我们想象的那样。戴夫退出了，而我留下来拍摄了第二季，
we all thought it was gonna be a little something, and she was wonderful lady, really liked her. And the guys who were part of that group, who was Jay Tarsus and Tom, those guys, they were part of it. So we went, well, their pedigree's really good. And it wasn't quite what we thought it would be. And Dave bailed, and I stuck around for the second iteration,
那真的太有趣了，老兄。我当时有了一点……我买得起一辆本田了，一辆本田思域。我能……我记得开着车去MTM工作室上班，心想：“我的生活不可能再美好了。”“我的生活不可能比这更好了。”而且我当时挣的……你还记得那个吗？
which was so fun, man. I had a little, I could afford a Honda, a little Honda Civic. And I could, I remember driving to work down to MTM Studios thinking, there's no way this could get better. There's no way my life could get better than this. And I was making, you remember that?
我的意思是，你会想，看看你挣的这些钱，其实并不多，然后你会说：“你在开玩笑吧？我居然有一个相对干净的小公寓。”你知道的，“我有一辆车。”哦，天哪，这感觉太棒了。你刚才正切中了要害，那种美妙的时刻，你们也知道的，比如当你得到第一份工作时，你会想：“我他妈在干这个。”
I mean, you go, look what you're making, and it wasn't much, and you go, are you kidding me? I have a little apartment that's relatively clean. You know, I got a car. Oh man, it's so fucking great. You just hit something, that sweet spot of that, you guys know too, like when you get that first gig where you go like, I'm fucking doing this.
我在干这个呢。我有钱拿，而且我在干这个。我记得《威尔和格蕾丝》（Will and Grace）的第一年，我当时27岁，我心想：“哦，我下周肯定会被炒鱿鱼的，我敢肯定。”当然，对吧，但在当时这并不重要。你只管放手去干。你演过《威尔和格蕾丝》。
I'm doing this. And I'm getting paid and I'm doing this. And I remember the first year of Will and Grace, I was 27 years old, I was like, oh, I'll get fired next week, I'm sure. Sure, right, but it doesn't matter at the time. You go for it. You were on will and grace.
原来是这样。迈克，我想回到《阴间大法师2》（Beetlejuice 2）的话题。对，看起来太棒了。当你接到……对，看起来太惊艳了。当你答应出演那部电影时，你有没有想过：“哦，天哪……”而在化妆间的头一天，你会想：“我为什么要接这个，
That's what it is. Michael, I wanna go back to the Beetlejuice 2. Yeah, looks incredible. When you got, yeah, it looks amazing. When you got the, when you said yes to doing that, were you like, oh man, and the first day in the makeup trailer, you're like, why did I put this,
我得把……我为什么要答应？我得戴上假发，我得把那该死的泥土抹在脸，我得画上黑眼圈……”还是说你会想：“不，这太棒了。”其实是第二种反应，就像是：“这太棒了。”因为你得明白，这部电影筹备了很长时间，虽然不像你想象的那样一帆风顺，对吧？
I gotta put, why did I say yes? I gotta put the wig on, I gotta put the fucking did I put this, I gotta put the wig on, I gotta put the fucking dirt on my face, I gotta put the black circles, or you're like, no, this is awesome. It was, no, it was the second, it was like, this is awesome, because you have to understand, this is a long time in the making, but not so as you'd know it, right?
对，因为我认识的每个人多年来一直在问：“为什么他们不拍续集？为什么他们不拍续集？”所以它终于来了？因为你无法复制我们当年创造的东西。你根本写不出来。想象一下，当许多剧本其实都是即兴创作的时候，你怎么去试着写出那样的东西？
Yeah, because everybody I knew for years were like, why don't they do a sequel, why don't they do a sequel, so finally it's here? Because you can't recreate what we made. You can't write it. Imagine trying to write it when a lot of the writing just happened, you know? It wasn't on the page so much,
它很大程度上并不在剧本里，尽管有一部分在，而且有些部分非常精彩，那个世界也非常棒。你会想“再拍一次”。你会发现，事情根本不是这么运作的。哪怕是在最精妙的剧本里，你知道的，你可以找来拉里·格尔巴特（Larry Gelbart）或尼尔·萨蒙（Neil Simon）或者任何才华横溢的作家，去试着复制，试着复制《窈窕淑男》（Tootsie）。
even though some of it was and some was terrific and the world was terrific. You go, do that again. You go, it doesn't work like that. Even in the most well-written, you know, you could take Larry Gelbord or Neil Simon or any of the brilliant writers and try to duplicate, try to duplicate Tootsie.
尽管其中有些部分确实很棒，整个世界也很棒。你会想，再来一次吧。而你会发现，事情并不是这样的。即使是在最优秀的剧本中，你知道的，你可以找来拉里·盖尔巴特、尼尔·西蒙或任何才华横溢的编剧，然后试图去复制，试图去复制《窈窕淑男》。
It would have never, you couldn't do it again. So imagine trying to do that. So obviously that we were never gonna do it. Then for years I thought, don't touch that. Leave that alone, man. That's a little piece. You just leave that alone, Don't touch it, but I liked it so much and Tim and I Worked so well together and I liked him so much that every once I would go What do you think and the answer was that and then it started getting more interesting to me?
这绝对是前所未有的，你再也无法复制了。所以想象一下要去尝试那种事。显然我们从来没打算这么做。然后多年来我都觉得，别碰那个。离它远点，伙计。那是很小的一块。你就离它远点，别去碰它，但我太喜欢它了，而且蒂姆和我合作得非常默契，我太喜欢他了，以至于我每隔一段时间就会问：“你觉得怎么样？”得到的回答都是那样，然后这对我开始变得更有趣了。
And I suggest that I'd like to do that again then at that time passed and then I thought it was done. So when it came around again, we'd see scripts now and then, and they just didn't work. And then these guys kind of got it, and went, whoa, this could be good. So Tim started talking to me about it. He had to finish something.
我暗示过我还想再做一次，然后时间流逝了，接着我以为这事已经结束了。所以当它再次出现时，我们偶尔会看到一些剧本，但它们就是行不通。然后这些家伙算是琢磨过味儿来了，觉得，哇，这可能会很棒。于是蒂姆开始跟我谈论这事。他得先把手头的东西忙完。
And so to answer your question, then you say, okay, I'm in. I had done a bunch, I direct this movie, and I act in another movie and another one and I was a little tired and I thought I would like another two months just to chill and kind of ramp it up and I didn't get it and I thought, fuck it, let's go do it. So we went to go make it and as I'm sitting in that makeup trailer that you mentioned, I remember going, this is really fun and I I'm really excited, and I'm nervous,
所以为了回答你的问题，当时你会说，好吧，我加入。我已经拍了不少了，我导演了这部电影，又在另一部和又一部电影里演戏，我当时有点累了，心想我需要再有两个月来放松一下、调整好状态，但我没能如愿，心想，去他的吧，我们开干吧。于是我们着手去拍了。正如你所提到的，当我坐在那个化妆车里时，我记得当时的感觉是，这真的很有趣，我真的很兴奋，也很紧张，
because I go, can you pull this off again? And can you do it? Because don't do it if you don't look stupid, and not just for me, don't fuck this thing up, you know? And so what hit me was I was sitting in the makeup trailer, going, yeah, here we go, that's right, and trying to explain to the woman, nah, it's got to, not quite, you know, we go, that's right, and trying to explain to the woman, nah, it's gotta, not quite, you know,
因为我在想，你还能再次成功吗？你还能做到吗？因为如果你看起来不够滑稽，那就别干了，不仅仅是为了我，别把这事搞砸了，你知道吗？所以击中我的感受是，我当时坐在化妆车里，心想，对，我们上，就是这样，然后试图向那位女士解释，不，必须得……不太对，你知道的，我们说，对，就是这样，试图向那位女士解释，不，必须得……不太对，你知道的，
talking her through that. And then we were getting there and getting ready to do it and about three days in, I went, there's something wrong and I don't know what's wrong. There's something off. It wasn't horrible, I just... Justin Theroux. It's Justin Theroux.
一边跟她沟通一边调整。然后我们到了那里，准备开拍，大约三天后，我觉得，有什么地方不对劲，但我不知道哪里不对。有什么东西感觉怪怪的。倒不是说有多糟，我只是……贾斯汀·塞洛克斯。是贾斯汀·塞洛克斯。
He comes in without any sleeves on. He's so funny in this, dude, he's so funny in this. I don't buy it. Yeah. We'll wait and see. There's something wrong. I so funny in this. I don't buy it. We'll wait and see. I'll be the judge, I'll be the judge. All right, so listen to this. So I'm sitting there, I go, I don't know what this is,
他穿着无袖衣服就进来了。他在里头太逗了，老兄，他在里头太逗了。我不买账。行吧。咱们拭目以待。有什么地方不对劲。我太逗了。我不买账。咱们拭目以待。我来当裁判，我来当裁判。好吧，听着。所以我就坐在那儿，心想，我不知道这到底是什么，
and I'm sitting in the makeup trailer, and I'm going, yeah, this is fun, I'm having fun, but what is bugging me? And I looked in the mirror, and I went, I got it, I know what it is. And I don't know about you guys, but I don't look at makeup anymore. I should go check more often in the monitor. I know I've made huge errors, but I don't look
我坐在化妆车里，心想，对，这挺有意思的，我也挺开心的，但到底是什么在烦扰我呢？我照了照镜子，心想，我明白了，我知道是什么了。不知道你们大家怎么样，反正我再也不看定妆照了。我应该更经常去监视器前看看。我知道我曾犯下过巨大的错误，但我不再去看
at things anymore, just go do it and I go home. I looked in the mirror and I went, I got it, I know what it is. This thing we created came out of nowhere. It just came out of this note. When I looked in the mirror, I saw toys. I went, this is fucked up. I saw, you know what I mean?
那些东西了，直接开拍然后就回家。我照了照镜子，心想，我明白了，我知道是什么了。我们创造的这个东西是凭空出现的。它就是从这个音符里蹦出来的。当我照镜子时，我看到了玩具。我心想，这太操蛋了。我看到了，你知道我的意思吗？
I saw little Beetlejuice toys. It looked like, you know what I mean? It looked like keychains and it looked like mugs. The commercial part of it that it had become. All the merch. Yeah, and it wasn't that that's a bad thing. It It was oh that perception is yeah, we've seen them because we've seen it on t-shirts We've seen I go did you change the look at all? No, that's interesting. I didn't I went a little bit Yeah, there was something with the hair that wasn't working
我看到了小精灵回魂的玩具。看起来像，你知道我的意思吗？看起来像钥匙扣，看起来像马克杯。它已经变成了一种商业化的东西。所有的周边产品。对，并不是说这是件坏事。而是“哦，原来这就是人们的看法啊，对，我们见过它们，因为我们在T恤上见过，我们见过”我问：“你把造型改过吗？”“没有。”“哦，这很有趣。”我没改，我稍微……对，头发有点地方不对劲。
I went now that's that never really looked exactly like that and you're trying to like and then you go Get that whatever it takes to get that out of your brain, just go back to what made you even think of this friggin' thing. It's a derivative, it's based on an impression. I remember feeling that way with writers on who would go, all of a sudden you'd read a script and they'd go and they'd have your character
我心想，现在看来，那个造型从来没完全长那样过，你试图去……然后你会想：不管付出什么代价，把那个从你脑子里赶出去，回到最初让你想到这个破玩意的初心。这是衍生出来的，它基于一种印象。我记得当时和那些编剧合作时也有这种感觉，他们会突然写出一个剧本，然后让你的角色
do something in a way. Oh, they want me to do it basically because they saw me do this in other times, but they don't realize that in other times, my character did that because it was organic to what was happening. Now they just want to see the trick. They don't want to see what led up to the trick.
以某种方式做一件事。哦，他们想让我这么做，基本上是因为他们看我在其他作品里这么做过，但他们没有意识到，在其他作品里，我的角色之所以那样做，是因为那是契合当时情境的自然流露。现在他们只想看那个噱头。他们不想看导致这个噱头发生的过程。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Do you know what I mean? And you'll never do it as well. Yeah, you'll never do it as well. How did you fix that, Michael? How did you make a friend of the- Psychologically, you had to go wipe that out of your brain, take it out of your brain.
对，对，对。你知道我的意思吗？而且你再也演不出那种效果了。对，你再也演不出那种效果了。迈克尔，你是怎么解决这个问题的？你用了什么方法和它——在心理上，你必须把它从你的脑子里抹掉，把它从你的脑子里拿出来。
Find a new version of them, yeah? Yeah, no, you know, when you go on set, go what was the thing originally? What was this thing originally? Just go be that again. Make it yours again. Yeah, make it yours again. How did we come up with this crazy thing?
找到他们的一个新版本，是吧？对，不，你知道的，当你去到片场时，要想：最初的东西是什么？最初的这个东西到底是什么？再去把它演出来。重新让它属于你。对，重新让它属于你。我们当时是怎么想出这个疯狂的玩意的？
And what was hard about that was there were certain things in this, look man, I'm on record saying how good this thing is. I'm not gonna go on and on. It's so good. But when I go on the set, there were things in the script, shows you how smart I am,
这其中困难的地方在于，这里面有些东西——听着，老兄，我有据可查地说过这东西有多好。我不会没完没了地夸。它真的太棒了。但当我去片场时，剧本里有些东西——这说明我有多聪明，
that I remember reading the script, go, ooh, this could work. I go, I don't know about that. Tim likes that idea. I don't think that idea's good. Three of them. I was wrong on all three. I was wrong about, I was dead wrong. When I saw it, I don't think that idea's good. Three of them. I was wrong on all three. I was wrong about, I was dead wrong.
我记得读剧本时心想，哦，这可能会行得通。我说：“我对这个存疑。”蒂姆喜欢那个主意。我觉得那个主意不太好。有三个地方。这三个我全都猜错了。我关于那些的想法是大错特错。当我看到它时，我心想：我觉得那个主意不太好。有三个地方。这三个我全都猜错了。我关于那些的想法是大错特错。
When I saw it, I went. He's just a remarkable filmmaker. I mean, the thing, he's never done anything easy. Not once. No, no. Edward Scissorhands, you know? Yeah. Incredible.
当我看到它时，我心想。他真是一位杰出的电影制作人。我是说，这家伙从来没做过任何一件简单的事。一次也没有。没有，没有。比如《剪刀手爱德华》，你知道吗？太不可思议了。
His degree of difficulty that he takes on and just drills it every single time. I don't feel like- Except for Carol Nail Clipper feet. Do you think- Which was underrated, but. So do you guys do, so you do this and like you've gone on the record saying
他所挑战的难度系数以及每次都完美完成的水平。我感觉——除了“卡罗尔趾甲剪脚”。你觉得——虽然那被低估了，但。所以你们做这个，所以你们做这个，就像你们已经公开表示过
it's gonna be great. I mean that is a lot of pressure, right? Yeah. And you have this thing, this iconic thing that you guys create and you're like, I'm thing that you guys create, and you're like, I'm sure when you're reading it or you're doing it, you're thinking like, fuck man, if we don't drill this, we got a target on our fucking back.
这将会是一部大作。我的意思是，这压力太大了，对吧？是的。而且你们有这样一个东西，你们创造的这个标志性的东西，你会觉得——我确信当你在阅读剧本或在拍摄时，你会想：操，老兄，如果我们没把这事办妥，我们的后背可就成了众矢之的了。
People are gonna come for us. Yeah, honestly, I didn't know like. But it's team sports, right? You don't really take, do you take it on individually? No, right? I mean, don't you sort of, do you get that sense when you're working on something that we're all kind of rowing in the same direction
人们会冲着我们来的。是的，老实说，我不知道。但这是团队运动，对吧？你不会真的去独自承担，你是个人承担的吗？不会吧，对吧？我是说，难道你没有那种感觉吗？当你参与某项工作时，我们大家其实都在朝着同一个方向划桨，
and that it's not really on you? Because you- If you're healthy, yeah. Yeah, yeah. Do you find yourself in that position as often as you want to, mentally? Good question. Yeah, mostly, I think.
这其实并不是你一个人的责任？因为你——如果你身体健康的话，会的。对，对。你在精神上能像你希望的那样经常处于那种状态吗？好问题。是的，大部分时候，我想。
I think there's a part of me, I know I'm not saying I'm not being humble here, there's a part of me that's just plain, mostly I think. I think there's a part of me, I know I'm not being humble here, there's a part of me that's just plain stupid, I think. There's a part of me that just goes, I don't know, I don't think of some of these things that other people think, and I don't know what that comes from, but I just don't. Sometimes I do, and I certainly was nervous
我觉得我的一部分——我不是说我在这里表现得谦虚——我的一部分就是单纯的、大多数时候我觉得。我觉得我的一部分——我不是说我在这里表现得谦虚——我的一部分就是单纯的愚蠢，我想。我的一部分只会觉得：我不知道，我不会去想其他人会想的那些事情，我不知道这源于什么，但我就是不去想。有时我会想，而且我确实曾为
about going back into it, only to say, can I do this? Not just do it and get through it, but go, can you get there? Because it's deserving of you being good. You need to be good. And in terms of what me talking about, I'll tell you, when I say I don't care
重回这个角色感到紧张，唯一的念头是：我能做到吗？不仅仅是把它演完就完事了，而是去想：你能达到那个高度吗？因为它值得你把它演好。你需要演好。就我所说的那种情况，我告诉你，当我大谈特谈我不在乎别人怎么看它时，
what anybody else thinks of it, I'm willing to say what I think about it because this is just how I feel about it. There's movies I've seen and you guys have seen that people have hated and I went, not me, I love this movie. Or other movies where you go, I don't get what people are raving about.
我愿意说出我自己的看法，因为这就是我对它的真实感受。有些电影，我看了，你们也看了，别人恨之入骨，而我却觉得：我不这样，我爱死这部电影了。或者还有别的电影，你会觉得：我不明白大家为什么对它赞不绝口。
Me, I don't care, every person I've ever run into for the rest of my life could say, boy, that second Beater News really sucked. I'd go, not to me. I mean, it has so many elements. It's so beautiful, first of all, physically. And you kind of care. And I'm telling you, every fucking person is funny in this.
对我来说，我才不管呢，我这辈子遇到的每一个人都可以说：“天啊，那第二部《阴间大法师》太烂了。”我会说：对我来说可不是。我是说，它有太多的元素了。首先，从视觉上它就太美了。而且你会在乎。我告诉你们，这里面的每一个人他妈的都太逗了。
I mean, Justin is funny. Catherine is funnier than she was in the first one. And just for the audience, it is a biopic, yeah? Yes. Yes. Thank you. Yeah. Well, I just wanted more... It's based on a true story. It's based on a true story. It's based on a true story. It's a true story of Beetlejuice, the character who goes to the cross.
我是说，贾斯汀很搞笑。凯瑟琳比她在第一部里还要搞笑。为了观众着想，这是一部传记片，对吧？是的。是的。谢谢。是的。好吧，我只是想要更多……这是根据真实故事改编的。这是根据真实故事改编的。这是根据真实故事改编的。这是《阴间大法师》的真实故事，这个角色经历千难万险……
You know what it is. It's licensed just to go out and be silly. Yeah, I love that. I love that. I love it. Man, well, look, like we say, we've taken up too much of your time. I could talk to you forever, man. Way too much. Like an hour. Way too much. I know, I know, I know. Yeah, really.
你知道这是什么。它就是获得授权可以去尽情胡闹。是的，我喜欢这样。我喜欢这样。我喜欢。老兄，好吧，听着，就像我们说的，我们占用你太多时间了。我能跟你聊一万年，老兄。太多了。像一个小时。太多了。我知道，我知道，我知道。是的，真的。
And we're just, what a thrill to have you, man, on the show. You're just, I just love that, like Jason said, that you're still doing it, that you're still rising. You're still doing incredible stuff. You keep surprising us and mixing it up. And might I add that you look fucking fantastic. Yeah, you do.
我们只是——能邀请你上节目，老兄，真是太荣幸了。你真的——就像杰森说的，我太喜欢你还在继续创作，你依然在不断攀登。你还在创作不可思议的作品。你不断给我们带来惊喜，不断尝试新风格。我能不能补充一句，你看起来帅呆了。对，你确实很帅。
Yeah, you look great. Look at you. I haven't seen you in 30 years. You look fucking great, you sound you do. Yeah, you look great. Look at you. I haven't seen you in 30 years. You look fucking great, you sound great. You don't sound crazy. I hope I'm not crazy ever, you know what I mean? None of us get crazy.
对，你看起来气色真好。看看你。我30年没见你了。你看起来帅极了，声音听起来……确实如此。对，你看起来气色真好。看看你。我30年没见你了。你看起来帅极了，声音听起来棒极了。听起来一点也不疯狂。我希望我永远不要发疯，你知道我的意思吗？我们谁也没有发疯。
You're kind, you're appreciative. Yeah. You've done it all. And I mean that in the best way because you've done it all and you've got your fucking feet on the ground. Let me ask you a question. If I would do the show every day, would I get this? Yeah, no, not really.
你很善良，很懂得欣赏。是的。你经历过这一切。我是以最好的方式这么说的，因为你经历过这一切，而且你脚踏实地。让我问你一个问题。如果我每天都做这个节目，我也会有这种待遇吗？是的，不，其实不会。
No, you would not. It's usually just once. That's a fucking good question, by the way. That's a good question. No, we'd turn on you pretty quick. I like the read, Jason. What does it mean? I'm being honest, not probably. It's just the once.
不，你不会的。通常只有一次。顺便说一句，这是个非常好的问题。这是一个好问题。不，我们很快就会对你倒戈相向的。我喜欢这个解读，杰森。这是什么意思？我说的是实话，大概不会。只有这么一次。
We'd turn on each other. It doesn't take much for us to turn on each other. It happens pretty quick. Yeah, immediately we'd put you right in the stew. You'd get it as hard as we do. Yeah, but what a thrill, man. It was so great to talk to you in Beetlejuice, Beetlejuice. Man, I'm excited. Yeah, all right. Thanks, Michael. Thanks, guys.
我们会互相倒戈的。我们不需要花太多时间就会互相倒戈。这发生得相当快。是的，我们会立刻把你扔进大熔炉里。你承受的打击会和我们一样狠。是的，但这太荣幸了，老兄。能跟你聊《阴间大法师2》真是太棒了。老兄，我很兴奋。好吧。谢谢你，迈克尔。谢谢你们，伙计们。
Come on back out of Montana and come hang out with us. All right, thank you. Honestly, it was really fun. Thank you. Thanks, man. Good to see you, Michael. All right, brother. Thank Honestly, it was really fun. Thank you. Thanks, man. Good to see you, Michael. All right, brother. Thank you, buddy, bye. You've been stealing Michael Keaton's shit for years.
快从蒙大拿回来，跟我们一起聚聚。好的，谢谢你们。老实说，这真的很有趣。谢谢。谢谢，老兄。很高兴见到你，迈克尔。好吧，兄弟。老实说，这真的很有趣。谢谢。谢谢，老兄。很高兴见到你，迈克尔。好吧，兄弟。谢谢你，伙计，再见。你多年来一直在偷迈克尔·基顿的梗。
I know, and I didn't want to embarrass him as well because, and I've, you know, got to know him just to say hello over the last five, six years or something, we'd see each other and stuff. And you know where I always talk to him, JB? Conan's Christmas party. Oh, you know him. Oh, my.
我知道，我也不想让他觉得尴尬，因为，你知道的，在过去这五六年里，我和他也算认识了，也就是打个招呼的交道，我们会见到彼此之类的。你知道我总是在哪里跟他聊天吗，JB？柯南的圣诞派对。哦，你认识他。哦，天哪。
It's true, I do. You're gonna get invited this year again. Don't you? You mentioned his name to me. But, and I always talk to him about stuff and I always tell him how much, and he's a big hockey fan, he's a big Penguins fan. So we talk hockey and then last year
真的，我确实认识。你今年还会受邀的。不是吗？你向我提起过他的名字。但是，我总是跟他聊各种事，我总是告诉他我有多——而且他是个超级冰球迷，是个超级匹兹堡企鹅队球迷。所以我们聊冰球，然后去年
he was really kind to me, said something really nice about me on Colbert, which was a fucking thrill of a lifetime. But anyway, so we, yeah, yeah, yeah. And I just love the way he does it. And it's the only impression I've ever done. And I don't want to, and he doesn't know this is of him, but it's an impression of him from gung ho.
他对我和蔼可亲，在斯蒂芬·科拜尔的节目上说了我很多好话，这真是我这辈子极其激动的事。不管怎样，所以我们，对，对，对。而且我太喜欢他那种表演方式了。这是我唯一模仿过的梗。我不想——而且他不知道这是在模仿他，这是模仿他演的《超级魔鬼党》里的样子。
We didn't even talk about that. he doesn't know this is of him, but it's an impression of him from gung ho. Uh-huh. We didn't even talk about that. I go. Do it? I go. Me. They're coming to you, the Japanese, they bought the car plant?
我们甚至都没聊过这个。他不知道这是在模仿他，这是模仿他演的《超级魔鬼党》里的样子。嗯哼。我们甚至都没聊过这个。我说。来一段？我说。我。他们要来找你们了，那些日本人，他们买下了汽车厂？
That's really good. Listener, if you could see it. I mean, people can't see it. If you could see it. If you could see it, it's good, right? You'd say. It's really good. Close.
这真的很棒。听众朋友们，要是你们能看到就好了。我是说，大家看不到。要是你们能看到的话。要是你们能看到的话，这很棒，对吧？你们会这么说的。这真的很棒。接近了。
Close. Yeah. Yeah, I've just been such a fan of his. And like, I mean, Jay, you pointed out, I mean, he does seamlessly between comedy and drama and absurdism and just everything. Yeah, and I like what you said. My life, have you ever watched My Life?
接近了。对。对，我一直以来都是他的超级粉丝。而且，杰伊，正如你所指出的，我是说，他在喜剧、正剧、荒诞剧之间游刃有余，以及各种风格之间转换自如。对，我喜欢你刚才说的话。我的一生，你看过《我的生命》吗？
No. Oh. I think I probably have. It's a fucking, it's so great and sad and oh my god so good. Anyway. What do you say Jay? Well just that he's reached such an enormous height of success and relevance yet he can still go to the market. Yeah. And he can still get a movie financed. Like that's really hard. I don't know if he could. Yeah he could. He could go to the market for sure,
没有。哦。我想我大概看过了。那真的是——太棒了，太悲伤了，天哪，太好看了。不管怎样。你觉得呢，杰伊？我是说，他达到了如此巨大的成功和影响力的高度，但他依然能去市场上买东西。对。而且他还能为主演的电影拉到投资。这真的很难。我不知道他能不能。对，他能。他绝对能去市场上买东西，
because he's not a celebrity. He's just a really, really well-respected, very famous actor that can do anything, and people go to see him. Yeah, and I like what you said, Jason, about the, you can't really nail him down, like you can't, or maybe you said it well, that you can't...
因为他不是那种浮夸的名人。他只是一个真正备受尊敬、非常著名的演员，演什么都能成，人们都会去看他演的电影。对，杰森，我喜欢你刚才说的那点，关于你真的无法彻底定义他，就像你无法——或者也许你表达得很好，你无法……
You can't label him. Yeah, you can't label him, right. I love that, that's so true. By the way, that movie, My Life, is about a guy who's gonna die and his son's gonna be born. It's with Nicole Kidman, I think, and he leaves videos for his son because he's not gonna meet him.
你无法给他贴标签。对，你无法给他贴标签，没错。我太喜欢这个了，太真实了。顺便说一句，那部电影《我的生命》，讲的是一个男人即将死去，而他的儿子即将出生。主演好像有妮可·基德曼，他给儿子留下了录像带，因为他将无法陪伴儿子长大。
Oh, geez. And how to live his life, what to do, and how to do stuff. If you're looking to get rid of any tears, I guess you just dial that up. I wish I could hug you guys right now. Dump some. Hey, on that ranch that he was living on, do you think there were a lot of animals around there?
哦，天哪。还有怎么过他的一生，该做些什么，以及怎么处理事情。如果你想把眼泪哭干的话，我想你只要点开这部电影就行了。我现在真想给你们一个拥抱。倾泻一些。嘿，在他住的那个牧场上，你觉得周围有很多动物吗？
Like, what kind of animals do you think there were? I hope your fucking mic cuts out. I hope the electricity goes out of your house, right? Rrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr Wait, no, like there's probably like cows and there's probably like bigger cows and like chickens. You mean like some bison? Bison! Bye! Bye! SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarff. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
比如说，你觉得那里有什么样的动物？我希望你他妈的麦克风断电。我希望你家停电，对吧？滋——————等等，不对，就像可能有很多奶牛，可能还有更大的奶牛，还有鸡。你是说像野牛之类的？野牛！再见！拜！SmartLess是由本杰明·巴尔比科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗勃·阿尔姆贾夫100%有机手工打造的。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。